manoury elle a passé toute sa vie sur
l'aide sociale à son président claude
n'zita
pendant 50 ans puis de sortir enfin de
place depuis la fin février elle suit
une formation d'assistant cuisinière je
réintègre le marché tranquillement puis
c'est ce que je voulais faire je suis
très très heureuse moi de l'opportunité
comme comores par ici avant la pandémie
des 500 emplois qu'il ya une quinzaine
de participants à la fois sont
maintenant 25 à suivre la formation de
cinq à six mois soixante dix pour cent
des participants était auparavant sur
l'aide sociale 10% recevait de
l'assurance-emploi et 20% n'avait aucun
revenu
on retrouve des gens qui ont un goût de
sortir on peut pas sortir maintenant
écoute partout ils voient pour eux la
seule façon de ce qu'on a en main
maintenant ils viennent le matin sont
motivés ils sont enchantés d'être aussi
créé un réseau de contacts aussi
il a fallu par contre revoir le modèle
d'affaires puisque la moitié des revenus
provenaient d'événements comme des
mariages ou des funérailles
mais en misant sur ses repas congelés
l'organisme a réussi à maintenir ses
activités
on a développé un marché justement qu'on
avait pas été chercher on avait une
clientèle plus âgée
présentement depuis la pandémie ne
prenant notre clientèle a augmenté on
retrouve le même tout le monde des
familles comme les participants sont de
jeunes décrocheurs dans ces détenus ou
des mères de famille monoparentale qui
n'ont pas été sur le marché du travail
depuis plusieurs années ils ont tous un
suivi personnalisé avec une des deux
intervenantes sociales avons une
structure de ville
je restais là à telle heure à telle
heure on mange à tallard on bosse autant
salah facile pour nous mais pour les
autres c'est difficile parce que il faut
qu'ils engagent dans une nouvelle sphère
de vie un nouveau mode de vie qui ne
connaissent pas oublier qu est ce qu est
un négateur le monde qui est correct
les outils pour aider à sortir de la
marque c'est sûr que ça fait chaud au
but
d'avoir confiance en nous on sait ce que
ça me donne moi j'ai commencé à voir et
comprendre
en plus d'apprendre à cuisiner les
participants apprennent à travailler en
équipe et à prendre des initiatives
je les vois les résultats je n'y vois il
ya des gens au premier à égard tu
pensais qu'il s'en sortirait pas ou qui
rend nulle pa mais moi je les ai vus se
trouver des emplois ces gens là sans
problème l on a à peu près un an
première semaine qui nous appellent
minimum nous notre objectif c'est que
ces gens-là fermin leur part qu on ne
veut pas quitter avant la faire qui
puisse sortir justement avec toutes les
compétences et on travaille beaucoup les
attitudes aussi également environ 90%
des participants retournent sur le
marché du travail après leur passage ici
et 40% d'entre eux reprennent aussi
leurs études à temps partiel et trois
ans après leur formation les trois
quarts des participants sont toujours
actifs sur le marché du travail il se
marie claude morin radio-canada asséner
des laurentides